hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute wieder akinator
das ist diese person hier in diesem
spiel geht es da
schaut euch einfach mal letztes video
zum akinator an da
zieht man glaube ich worum es geht halt
sie euch fragt wieso hintergrund so
tröpfelt deswegen wenn wir uns die
letzten zehn spiele anschauen denen der
ukulele wurde gespielt viel wurde auch
gespielt
falls ihr film ich kenne jetzt aus
meinem ersten part von chk en detail
verlinkt ech kann ich quasi aus
irgendwelchen sachen in welche monster
zusammenbauen und das macht sehr viel
spaß ihr könnt mir übrigens mal einfach
akinator challenges in die kommentare
schreiben und dann das immer diese
youtube frage zu beginnen kommen
ich hätte bock dass sie mir so was
schreibt wie herr luca drückt auch mal
die ganze zeit nur auf ja- oder mach
doch mal das du auf ich weiß nicht
klickst die ganze zeit ihr kommt da
bestimmt auf kreative ideen oder dass
ich jedes mal eine münze schmeißen muss
welche antwort ich nehmen darf irgendwie
sowas finde ich mal ganz cool mich würde
jetzt einfach eine sache mal ganz kurz
interessieren die ich jetzt bei martina
versuchen werde die ein bisschen komisch
ist die sache hatte etwas mit mir zu tun
und warschau
das ist halt etwas sehr spezielles
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das
beschreiben soll was fakt nicht übel
aber irgendwie hakt akinator voll ist
deine figur älter als 36 klick auf nein
und er braucht erst mal 1000 jahre als
wenn man eine internetleitung so ein k
oder soja meine figur lebt in
deutschland
cook jetzt legt dass die 3000 jahre ich
weiß nicht ob der regen wirklich
irgendwie leid und kaputt gemacht ich
habe keine ahnung ob es besser ist aber
ich probier's mal hat seine figuren
handy nein hat sie nicht gehört eine
figur kraft da ja tut sie meine figur
ist leider keine flasche lieber clever
bot und die figur kopp doch nicht aus
einem mobilen geschäft das ist jetzt
eine schwierige sache ob meine figur
eine youtuber ist ich führt aber mal
sagen nee meine figur ist auch kein tier
und ist eine figur in kisten haus dabei
was ist eine pisten haus meine figur ist
auch keine maschine und manni figur hat
keine augen ist keine figur ein
pornostar wer erreicht diese fragen hat
eine figur was mit con kraft dazu tun
habe ich doch schon zwei mal ja gesagt
meine figur ist keine maschine und auch
keine roboter lieber clever aber ich
denke an wand lp
zombies terraria lp meine figur spielt
nicht in der serie doctor who mit meine
figur hat nicht nur der elektrizität zu
tun ja meine figur ist europäischer
staatsangehörigkeit und meine figur
diese fragen dauern wir sowas schon viel
zu lange alter ich weiß nicht ob gerade
einfach zehn trilliarden leute akinator
spielen aber an der stelle
ich bin am vorproduziert und habe den
letzten video nicht geschafft das zu
öffnen und heute ist der zehnte deswegen
wir sind natürlich in sieben wir können
heute drei zürich eröffnen luca der
einzige youtuber bei dem der kalender
überhaupt nicht funktioniert zwischen 80
und 49 cent gerechnet in zürcher nacht
haben wir diesen rotz drin dann haben
wir in türchen neuen noch ein weiteres
kleid ferien drin unter
apropos wir können ibm bei akinator
spielen ich breche das hier mal kurz
alles ab und geht zurück zum start und
geh jetz auch dass die kammer im
internet die seite legt nicht mal liebe
telekom wenn du das siehst kriege ich
vielleicht die bessere leitung
bitte ich habe eigentlich eine 50.000
leitung aber irgendwie kommen bei mir
noch 24.000 an oder so das sagt schon
hart ich habe in einem der letzten
videos diese kleine figuren namens
ariana die cavs keinen gefallen hat dann
gesagt wenn diese figur wirklich zum
akinator auch kommen sollte dann
schließlich meinen kanal dass schon
nichts nach ja meine figur würde durch
youtube berühmt lieber clever bot meine
figur trägt nicht eher männliche
kleidung ja meine figur gehört
contractor und jetzt warten wieder zehn
sekunden auf die nächste frage denn da
ist eine wägung heldt nein sie ist kein
held wir warten wieder 10.000 jahre bis
die nächste frage eingeblendet wie er
dies deine figur eine playmobil figur
ok
der moment der wahrheit hat deine figur
blondes haar naja also derzeit hat sie
braune haare aber zum zeitpunkt des
videos wo ich das gesagt hatte sie
glaube ich blonde haare
ja sie hat blonde haare ich denke marian
kraft das playmobil ariel eingereicht
von iks
ja es ist arien und arien wurde auch
schon
das videos ein paar tage alt freunde da
er ihn beim akinator eingereicht wurde
und ich sie gefunden habe muss ich jetzt
wohl leider
ich würde sagen lasten daumen hoch dabei
geht ja nicht weil man kanal jetzt
geschlossen